[Musique]
bonjour à tous et bienvenue sur le
plateau de dimanche en politique
aujourd'hui nous allons parler
d'économie et plus spécialement d'un
secteur qui pèse lourd en bourgogne
franche comté l'industrie avec une
question l'industrie médine france
at-elle encore un avenir
3 invité pour tenter de répondre à cette
question durant 30 minutes
tout d'abord isabelle laugerette vous
êtes secrétaire général de lui et même
comprenez que c'est l'union les
industries des métiers de la métallurgie
elle liens de soleil loi c'est le
département le plus industrielle de la
bourgogne
sylvian géante piccolo vous vous êtes
directeur général de sse coderre une
entreprise installée à pirée près de
besançon
vous travaillez à 95% pour l'automobile
et vous employez 110 personnes vous
appartenait également au conseil
d'administration du pôle véhicule du
futur
et puis philippe petitcolin c'est le
délégué cfe cgc de general electric à
belfort belfort donc qui compte
maintenant 3400 salariés
vous pouvez réagir commenter cette
émission grâce à twitter et au hashtag
dit mme paul bf sitcom dimanche en
politique
bourgogne franche comté alors on
commence bien sûr actualité oblige par
la copie de 19
on va commencer avec vous monsieur jean
piccolo dans votre entreprise
au début du confinement vous avez vu
votre activité chuter
on m'avait dit jusqu'à 80% aujourd'hui
vous allez tous alors aujourd'hui on a
retrouvé un volume d'activité qui est
celui que nous connaissions avant la
queue vide
nous avons traversé douze semaines avec
une baisse d'activité de l'ordre de 80%
une remontée progressive depuis le mois
de juin pour atteindre un niveau
stabilisé à partir de septembre et
octobre confirme la tendance donc
presque 100% presque 100% vous en saône
et loire les entreprises se porte-t-elle
aussi bien que ce que deere de monsieur
jean piccolo on peut difficilement
généralisée on nous avons des
entreprises qui effectivement ont
retrouvé une activité pleine mais
d'autres qui souffre encore énormément
qui se battent qui se bat vraiment
qu'ils croient
qu'ils essaient d'aller sur de nouveaux
marchés parce que véritablement c'est là
que les choses peuvent se faire mais on
peut difficilement généraliser une
reprise totale de l'activité oui ça va
pas bien notamment dans l'aéronautique
notamment dans l'aéronautique
effectivement voilà et il faut savoir
quand même que l'actualité économique a
été marquée en franche comté par deux
nouvelles importantes à savoir que skf
allant desaulniers supprimer 123 postes
sur les 350 donkey de leurs sites dans
le jura un site qui travaillent pour
l'aéronautique justement et que il ya
également une menace de fermeture du
site historique
jacob delafon a à dole donc à damparis
près de dole et puis vous monsieur petit
colas a sévi que comment l'aco vide à
general electric de choses tout d'abord
le marché de l'aviation qui s'effondrait
est donc un projet de diversification
qui a été annulée qui devait créer 200
emplois sur trois ans et deuxièmement
des activités en réduite l'ordre de 30 à
50% et génériques qui souhaitent
délocaliser délocalisé à chaque fois
c'est la réponse à tous les problèmes la
délocalisation donc quarante mille
heures qu'elle est délocalisée en arabie
saudite aux états unis mais grâce à un
accord de flexibilité qui consistait en
embaucher des intérimaires travailler
les samedis repoussé 10 jours de régates
les causes de la coved vous avez accepté
plus de souplesse bas la menace la
menace de délocalisation donc face à la
menace les instances syndicales ont été
responsables et ont proposé un projet
alternatif afin qu'on puisse réaliser
les quarante mille heures dans l'année à
partir de flexibilité c'est à dire
repoussé 10 rtt sur 2021 travailler les
samedis et faire appel à l'intérim
on va reparler tout ça et de la
situation de general electric
on va parler donc du poids de
l'industrie dans notre région la
bourgogne franche comté
c'est un poids énorme puisque un salarié
sur cinq travaille pour l'industrie 20%
quand on compare la population active et
la population qui est en industrie et
puis donc un salarié sur cinq qui
travaille dans l'une des 14 1700
entreprises industrielles de bourgogne
franche comté alors justement est ce que
cette multiplicité d'entreprise quinze
mille entreprises industrielles pour une
population d'hommes
3 millions d'habitants est ce que ça
veut dire que les entreprises ont des
tailles trop petit
d'après vous alors nous avons beaucoup
de pme effectivement la bourgogne
franche comté est un territoire
relativement vaste avec beaucoup de
ruralité et beaucoup de pme malgré tout
elles sont très proches de leurs
donneurs d'ordre on a énormément de
grands groupes en bourgogne franche
comté
donc c'est une force pour ces grands
donneurs d'ordres d'avoir ces pme quand
celle ci sous la main sous la main
exactement quand celle-ci innove
quand elle avance sur de nouveaux
marchés quand justement justement est-ce
que c'est pas trop petit pour justement
ce pays est un service recherche et
développement qui tienne la route oui
alors effectivement c'est une faiblesse
de nos pme
mais aujourd'hui l'intérêt c'est que nos
pme puissent ali en filière et ça c'est
quelque chose qui se fait beaucoup en
bourgogne franche comté on a quand même
de nombreuses filières organisées
moi je parlerai de la filière nucléaire
organisée avec un pôle de compétitivité
qui nucléaire valais ou qui regroupe
tous les acteurs de la filière nucléaire
et qui permet d'avancer de faire des
réponses à des appels à projets de
s'organiser de se structurer
donc c'est comme ça effectivement que
les pme peuvent avancer chez skoda
donc comme je disais tout à l'heure 110
salariés c'est petit pour avoir un gros
service de recherche et développement
effectivement dans une pme de 110
personnes
la mise en place d'un service recherche
et développement intégré l'entreprise
est quelque chose de compliqué mais on
peut saluer quand même des initiatives
possibles et notamment dans l'entreprise
codeurs nous avons réussi à monter un
programme avec un chiffre donc un
doctorant en partenariat avec
département de femto alors des bosses et
le grand laboratoire de l'université de
franche-comté ses seins dans un domaine
qui est celui dont on aura besoin dans
le futur à savoir la digitalisation des
données dont on va parler en ligne et
puis aussi avec un laboratoire de
mécanique donc il existe quand même
différent sur pour coopérer avec des
laboratoires surtout à besançon et puis
pour décrocher des marchés importants
vous êtes trop petit aussi non ça dépend
de la technologie que l'on peut avancer
effectivement dans certains cas on sera
trop petit en volume mais si on est sur
des secteurs technologiques particulier
où il ya peu de concurrence on peut
trouver matière à travailler alors vous
serrez à différence avec donc ces gens
qui parlent deux pays mm
vous c'est general electric c'est un
énorme groupe américain ce sont des
financiers ou des industriels qui sera
la tête de l'entreprise sont des
financiers
il n'y a plus de recherche de
développement dans les grands groupes
comme general electric
ils attendent que des petites
entreprises et des petits groupes
développe une technologie après les
rachète et après vous êtes en train de
vous parler de mercenaires clairement
oui
general electric n'a jamais investi dans
la recherche développement ils ont
acquis des entreprises qui avaient pris
des risques pas la notion de recherche
et développement pour un financier c'est
un coup donc un financier ne parle pas
de recherche développement il lui dit il
cherche de la rentabilité à très court
terme oui donc ce n'est pas compatible
de la recherche le principe de larges
développements c'est mettre de l'argent
à l'instant t pour avoir des retours sur
investissement plus tard alors vous vous
avez un actionnaire dans votre
entreprise c'est la famille bourgeois
qui est propriétaire également du groupe
bourgeois
ça rassure qu'on tournait directeur donc
d'un site comme ce coderre d'avoir à la
tête de l' usine des industriels et pas
des financiers j'exerce ce métier de
cadre dirigeant depuis 35 ans mais
depuis 35 ans au service d'entreprises
patrimoniales
donc je peux témoigner de tous les
avantages qu'il peut y avoir d'avoir des
familles qui s'inscrivent sur le temps
long et c'est le propre des entreprises
patrimoniales que de s'engager sur le
ton nom dans une perspective d'exister
dans dix ans dans 20 ans ce qui n'exclut
pas quand même la recherche d'une
certaine profitabilité puisque sans
résultat on peut pas aller bien loin au
niveau de la vie d'une entreprise
on va voir quelques chiffres doc la bêta
lurgi c'est presque 2000 entreprises en
bourgogne franche comté l'automobile 650
et puis le duclair 120 entreprises de
convois en effet donc de multiples
entreprises
est-ce que vous pensez que donc vous dit
regrouper des gens arriver à décrocher
des marchés
est ce que les chefs d'entreprise ils
sont prêts travailler avec des
concurrents c'est quand même à vouloir
demander beaucoup quand même
c'est à dire que dès l'instant
qu'aujourd'hui elles travaillent des
gens filière les toutes ces entreprises
là se sont organisés en filières où
s'organisent en filière et ça
effectivement du coup dans la filière
il y à des concurrents je reprends
l'exemple de la filière nucléaire
on va retrouver dans cette filière les
grands donneurs d'ordre les pme les
chercheurs les universitaires les
organismes de formation
enfin tous ces structures là qui vont
pouvoir ensemble être plus fort et ça je
pense qu'ils vont vraiment compris quand
on parle du coût et donc des faiblesses
des entreprises souvent les patrons met
en avance
le courant le coût du travail puisque
l'on dit toujours que le salarié
français coûte beaucoup plus cher
alors je veux pas vous faire réagir
c'était un peu une tarte à la crème mais
vous philippe petitcolin vous dites que
c'est un leurre scemama mensonges parce
que selon vous en faites par exemple
dans votre entreprise qui délocalise à
l'extérieur notamment en inde
le coût du travail dans une turbine ces
moines 5%
oui sur les très grosses turbines à gaz
le le coût de la main d'oeuvre ouvrière
c'est 7% et sur une centrale sa peine 1
% donc même s'il a travaillé des
esclaves gratuitement il n'arrivera
médias pour faire travailler des escales
1105 par mois le patron est visiblement
si c'était possible parce que je
n'aurais triplerait oui donc vous
tournez vous tournez le cou à une idée
reçue en fait après tout tout dépend en
fait de la part main d'oeuvre sol le
prix du produit sur une centrale
électrique
il ya très peu de produits qui sont
produits qui sont fabriqués en france et
sur le sous le coup d'une centrale c'est
dérisoire
on parle maintenant des forces des
atouts de nos entreprises en bourgogne
franche comté vous allez garder la
parole on va parler de la main d'oeuvre
vous en tant que syndicaliste où devait
être intarissable sur les qualités de la
main d'oeuvre française
oui pour general electric excellent ce
tome ce sont des centaines de centrales
conçus et installés à travers le monde
sur ce marché-là le sait on peut gagner
beaucoup d'argent comme perdre beaucoup
d'argent c'est vraiment l'expérience
expertise tous les projets réalisés à
travers le monde les partenaires et à
tisser à travers le monde qui permettent
de maîtriser le risque que les risques
qui sont très importants et general
electric ne comprends pas cette
compétence là et le délocalise dans les
régions au moyen-orient en chine et sera
conduit
du mit 18 à avoir un dérapage budgétaire
sur les projets de 1,8 milliard et 1000
entreprises dans le rouge
très bien on le made in france
quand vous vous entendez industries made
in france est ce que vous êtes aussi
tout de suite le luxe à cette somme est
digne france que c'est un super label de
qualité quand même oui alors je pense
que vous avez du grand public c'est le
luxe ce qui apparaît tout de suite bien
entendu on pense pas une centrale dit
que j'allais dire voilà tout à fait mais
vous pensez que c'est à un gage de
qualité pour l'extérieur
ah oui certainement oui bien sûr et de
toute façon c'est une réalité je pense
que quand on associe à l'ubs sont
associés savoir faire savoir faire
pointu ce savoir faire des salariés
exactement et ça c'est quelque chose qui
est vraiment à valoriser parce que je
pense que dans nos industries
vous parlez de du luxe on peut parler
d'un maroquinerie on peut parler de tout
un tas de choses mais on peut parler de
l'aéronautique on veut parler de toutes
nos industries qui utilisent au
quotidien savoir faire très pointu et
spécifiques et là c'est un vrai plus que
l'on a dans nos entreprises qui peut
être valorisé notamment avec je dirais
le développement de l'apprentissage que
l'on à aujourd'hui qui est une vraie
force
enfin enfin l'industrie à une autre
perception relève du grand public que ce
qu'elle était jusqu'à maintenant et je
me suis laissé dire que les cfa les
centres de formation des apprentis de
l'industrie avait réussi à remplir leur
classe cette année
alors oui pour les c'est bien pour ça
que je vous disais pour la première fois
du fils de douala nombreuses années on
va là l'apprentissage reprend des
couleurs
médine france ça veut dire exportations
vous chez secondaire vous exportez 60 %
de votre production entre nous quelle
est votre recette
vous avez un truc alors le truc lille et
surtout d'avoir des clients français qui
ont des bases à l'international dont
vous traitez pas directement avec
l'étranger en fait très peu mais de plus
en plus on reçoit des commandes
d'entreprises de droit nous français
c'est à dire lorsque l'on travaille avec
un valeo
un équipementier automobile sous
traitants te manges evra des commandes
des sites qui sont à l'extérieur de la
place en france
très bientôt nous allons maintenant
parler du rôle de l'état justement dans
l'industrie dans le maine made in france
la semaine dernière jeudi a nié ce
panier une hache et la secrétaire
chargée de la ministre euh pardon chargé
de l'industrie est en visite dans
l'entreprise corps d'une femme à chenôve
près de dijon
elle est venue présenter territoire
d'industrie un plan de l'état pour venir
en aide aux entreprises industrielles la
bourgogne franche comté est la première
région française à en bénéficier sur la
table 20 millions d'euros et quatre
objectifs on écoute ce plan
d'accélération de l'investissement dans
les entreprises industrielles
il a quatre objectifs qui correspondent
à nos ambitions de politique
industrielle la décarbonation la
modernisation de chaînes de production
d'un petit peu de retard par exemple par
rapport à l'allemagne
l'innovation parce que c'est ça qui va
nous permettre d'avoir des avantages
concurrentiels et d'inventer des
solutions de demain pour notamment
décarbonés l'économie et puis quatrième
élément c'est la relocalisation la
localisation de production qui sont qui
était auparavant fabriqué à l'étranger
[Musique]
territoire d'industrie selon marie-guite
dufay la présidente du conseil régional
bourgogne franche comté c'est 4000
emplois consolidés et 550 crée alors
vous vous avez été super heureuse quand
vous avez vu arriver là ministre de
l'industrie en bourgogne franche comté
alors le plan de relance effectivement
initié par le gouvernement est une vraie
chance pour les entreprises et en
bourgogne franche comté on a énormément
de dossiers qui ont été initiés et je
crois qu'on nous avons déjà utilisé une
grosse partie d'une enveloppe donc tant
mieux ça veut dire que les entreprises
continuent d'innover d'investir et de
croire en l'avenir donc ça c'était je
dirais un vrai plus pour l'avenir tant
mieux on pourrait juste mettre un petit
bémol c'est que ce plan de relance exclu
peut-être un peu les toutes petites
entreprises par le fait qu'il faille
investir de façon très importante pour
pouvoir en bénéficier vous en attendez
quoi de l'état vous des sous du soutien
des pas des sceaux disons que dire du
soutien parce que les sous c'est une
chose mais il faut qu'on ait un marché à
servir donc il faut aussi recréer les
conditions d'un marché et c'est
important aujourd'hui de noter que
l'état s'est engagé comme jamais ils
s'engagent et peut témoigner des
soutiens à travers le plan
garantis par l'état à des prêts et
garanties par l'état et puis le paiement
des du chômage
et puis le soutien pour les entreprises
qui avaient des angles ouvriers au
chômage
et puis aujourd'hui tout ce qui est
appel à projets qui sont en train de
d'amener digérer des subventions aux
entreprises qui sont les plus innovantes
je vais vous poser une question c'est
celle de ses stéphane que je relaie elle
s'adresse à vous particulièrement
est-ce qu'il faut mener une politique
nationaliste pour protéger l'industrie
il faut développer un sentiment de
patriotisme industriel ses délires
d'être fiers d'avoir des entreprises en
france d'être fiers d'avoir des salariés
qui sont ingénieux et de le dire nos
métiers ils réussiront par
l'intelligence au travail mais on ferme
pas les frontières aux concurrents
nationaliste c'est ça si on ferme les
frontières à l'entrée au risque de
fermer les frontières à la sortie une
question pour vous philippe petitcolin
elle et de pierres alors c'est plus une
d'ailleurs une constatation qu'une
question alors que pèse le gouvernement
français face à un grand groupe comme
general electric
quand il ya des accords qui ont été
signés entre depuis l'état français
des accords qui ne sont pas respectés
alors je signale juste 2014 rachat de la
branche alstom énergie par ji ji
s'engage à créer un millier d'emplois à
belfort et d'en faire un pôle mondial
pour l'énergie
six ans plus tard il y a en fait mille
emplois supprimés et puis le site et
démantibulé on dit démanteler donc par
appartements pratiquement par activité
quoi donc vous dites
le gouvernement a signé avec general
electric
il faut maintenant que l'état français
fasse respecter cette signature c'est
tout à fait et c'est le ministre actuel
travers la loi pacte qui a renforcé son
pouvoir de sanction envers des groupes
étrangers qui ont acquis des entreprises
dans les filiales dit stratégiques
l'énergie et stratégiques depuis
montebourg donc le ministre depuis
arnaud montebourg l'énergie a été
déclarée stratégique on est bien
d'accord tout avant ça n'était pas tout
à fait voilà je vous en prie donc depuis
l'énergie est stratégique et depuis 2010
le ministre a proposé un une loi qui
s'appelle la loi pacte qui permet de
sanctionner un investisseur étranger qui
ne respecteraient pas les accords avec
l'état français au regard de la filière
ji a déjà payé 50 millions d'euros
d'amendé ça c'est d'après après partie
d'accord parce que c'était un millier
d'emplois créés il y en a pas eu
cinquante mille euros par emploi non
créer 50 millions façade après un parti
je pense que ça doit pas gêner beaucoup
les comptes de general electric n'ont
ils touchent 25 millions de cice ceir
parents c'est pas on parle de 600
millions de bénéfices par fillol voilà
on est un plan social que l'année
dernière ça a coûté 100 millions
donc voilà c'est on est dans l'épaisseur
du trait ce que je disais c'est qu'à la
loi pacte le ministre
un pouvoir de police il peut sanctionner
ji hauteur du double du montant de
l'acquisition si l'accord n'est pas
respecté 12 milliards à l'acquis 12
milliard
ça veut dire qu'il a le biais de
négociations à hauteur de 24 milliards
il va pas vouloir froisser un
investisseur potentiel et un
gouvernement ami tout à fait c'est bien
le problème c'est que l'état un
positionnement ultra libérables alors
que la chine les etats unis protègent
leurs fleurons avec des lois
extraterritoriales la france elle a une
position ultra libérale et laisse ses
fleurons industriels qui ont été
construits sur le la à 40 public
on parle de d'alstom on peut parler de
technip on peut parler de alcatel ces
grands groupes délocalisent les brevets
délocalisent les profits dans les
paradis fiscaux et après des légalistes
des emplois sauf que maintenant en
termes de qu'ovide
le ministre le présent la république a
parlé de relocalisation nous nous disons
arrêtons déjà de délocaliser c'est plus
facile déjà voilà et vous vous vous
mobilisez à belfort et l'émission est
enregistrée vendredi elle sera diffusée
dimanche
donc hier il ya eu une manifestation un
appel à manifester justement avec
beaucoup d'élus qui vous soutiennent
parce que c'est quand même ça pèse son
poids general electric à belfort à main
tout le département reste et yvan dépens
d'alstom de maintenant general electric
donc à chaque fois que j'allais
électrique tous c'est tout l'emploi et
tout l'avenir
qui se trouve en réanimation à l'hôpital
sans jeu de mots tout à fait c'est ça
c'est ça
j'aurais bien qu'aux abords de la
troisième partie de cette émission donc
c'est 2021 et après est ce que vous avez
senti dans les entreprises là elles ont
amorti la crise pour celles qui vont
survivre il faut être prêt à rebondir
quand ça va repartir
ça c'est pas évident 1 c'est pas évident
d'autant qu'on a du mal à voir la fin de
cette crise sanitaire
donc ce qui pèse le plus dans les
entreprises je pense aujourd'hui en tout
cas ce qui pèse beaucoup c'est
l'incertitude de cette crise sanitaire
de l'évolution que ça pourrait avoir
dans les entreprises est effectivement
donc des conséquences économiques que ça
peut avoir chez eux
les entreprises ont beaucoup souffert en
2020 ça c'est sûr elles ont su rebondir
suivre reporter leur carnet de commandes
pour celles qui survivent alors jusqu'à
fin 2020 pour l'instant je pense qu'on
n'a pas vraiment de grosse casse on a
des entreprises en difficulté on en a
des qui sont en chômage partiel dont il
ya tout un tas de dispositifs qui ont
été mis en place
et heureusement qu'ils permettent de
limiter grandement la casse notamment
non un accord de branche qui permet donc
de limiter la casse dans la métallurgie
mais par contre 2021 notamment si je
prends l'exemple des pme qui sont en
grande majorité nos entreprises dans la
région très clairement elles ont très
peu de visibilité va pas de visibilité
pour 2021 et c'est ça la difficulté
donc je disais tout à l'heure vous
faites partie du pôle véhicule du futur
dans l'automobile vous vous êtes à 100%
chez scolaire donc très bien toute
l'automobile vous voyez comment l'année
2021 et le rebond on voit une activité
qui reste soutenue sur les plates formes
qui sont existantes notamment pour les
véhicules psa
il ya des perspectives pour les années à
venir qui sont qui sont robustes mais au
delà des volumes de production envie
série on a aussi toute cette dynamique
qui est porté par le pôle véhicule du
futur
je rappelle que le pôle du véhicule du
futur c'est 500 adhérents ses 450
entreprises à plus de 50 % de pme
et puis
une vision sur le temps long oui vous
m'avez dit quand on a préparé cette
émission à la transition écologique
c'est une opportunité
bon au début c'est une grosse contrainte
mais vous voyez comment donc l'avenir la
recherche le développement pour polluer
moi parce que c'est ça votre votre défi
le défi c'est polluer moins
et donc pour polluer mois il faut être
innovant il ya chaque fois que le monde
industriel la rencontre est un temps de
l'innovation
on aime un peu forcé la main de vata
force est effectivement et c'est la
difficulté du moment parce qu'on oppose
le véhicule traditionnel la motorisation
traditionnelle aux véhicules électriques
sachant que les deux continuent de
rechercher des solutions pour moins
polluer
il ya aussi l'hydrogène ya aussi
beaucoup beaucoup de deux pistes vous y
croyez vous à l'hydrogène
on y croit on y croit particulièrement
parce que ça peut déboucher sur des
productions qui peuvent venir chez nous
et nous avons des moyens de production
spécifique pour ce type d'activité vous
vous y croyez beaucoup à l'innovation et
la recherche et la voûte sorte est
peut-être un peu de votre rôle de
syndicaliste j'allais guerre
traditionnelle vous vous faites des
propositions fermes et très argumentée
pour l'avenir pour la recherche
tout à fait le l'hydrogène c'est
vraiment une opportunité pour l'avenir
aussi bien sur la partie énergie que la
partie mobilité et pour la première fois
dans l'histoire industrielle on a deux
mondes qui ne travaillait pas rassemble
le monde de la mobilité et le monde de
l'énergie les l'hydrogène en fait il ne
se conçoit en fait qu'à travers une
production verte et et à travers des
usages qui sont multiples et donc c'est
l'occasion pour nom créé tellement ça
veut dire quoi concrètement cdd bus à
hydrogène
concrètement c'est s'est produit de
l'hydrogène vert à partir de champs
photovoltaïques ou ou des éoliennes
d'après d'avoir des bus à hydrogène
d'avoir des des quartiers chauffer
fournir en électricité pas avec de
l'hydrogène s'est tous les comment dire
les véhicules dans polluants qu'on a
dans les gars dans les les ports dans
les aéroports tara qui peuvent passer à
l'hydrogène
c'est l'hydrogène avec la montée du
renouvelable
l'enjeu c'est le stockage on les
renouvelables c'est très bien mais ces
intermittents
quand on a pas de vent quand on a pas de
soleil qu'est ce qu'on fait on sait pas
stocker ligne on sait pas stocker
l'électricité
donc on a certes les barrages c'est cela
seul moyen qu'on a l'autre moyen c'est
de développer le stockage à partir de
l'hydrogène et l'hydrogène même s'il eût
pensé que là pour belfort pour les nord
franche comté il ya une opportunité ya
clairement une opportunité
c'est clairement ce que vous savez faire
vous avez la technologie ben parce qu'il
ya beaucoup de personnes qui sont lancés
dans des briques technologiques donc les
réservoirs
après il ya les piles à combustible
s'intéressent pas forcément à belfort
est ce qui manque en fait il ya déjà le
savoir faire et des savoir faire sur les
produits ce qui même une mairie xetra
elle veut pas acheter un réservoir
elle va acheter une solution complète où
on puisse vous savez produire et ça
c'est nos compétences à nous
d'intégrateur centrales électriques que
general electric veut se séparer et
c'est des compétences qui manquent dans
l'hydrogène
donc demain l'idée c'est que le nord
franche comté de n2 puisse avoir une
entité qui puisse fournir des solutions
complètes avec des composants qui sont
produits en local avec des investisseurs
locaux
quand l'intérêt local parce que notre
entreprise notre région
elle dépend du local si de nouveaux cd
financier qui viennent ici qui profite
de l'argent public et après quelques
discours là on peut qu'être qu'être
d'accord avec une production locale avec
le fait que les sous-traitants les
donneurs doivent travailler ensemble et
produire sur de nouveaux marchés mais
pas de financier a pas de fiancé j'ai
pas s'il faut le dire comme ça mais en
tout cas pouvoir travailler en local
avec les pme locales oui bien sûr mais
vous le défi c'est la robotisation la
digitalisation très rapidement parce
qu'il restait moins d'une minute
la digitalisation c'est un axe
extrêmement important parce que c'est
une meilleure connaissance de tous les
ingrédients qui font nos systèmes de
production
et puis avec les outils numériques ça
nous permet de calculer beaucoup plus
vite des solutions efficientes
très bien j'aimerais conclure cette
émission par une citation une citation
de saadiya zaïdi qui dit à l'avenir nous
verrons que les entreprises les plus
compétitives seront celles ayant investi
mathy massivement dans leur capital
humain donc les qualifications et des
compétences de leurs employés et cette
dame c'est pas n'importe qui c'est la
directrice générale du forum économique
mondial
et oui c'est la patronne de davos vous
acquiescez oui tout à fait d'accord
aussi moi aussi même les chefs
d'entreprise acquiesce oui parce qu'a
priori c'est quand même pas des
gauchistes à davos 1 2 vous êtes
d'accord quand même que nos cheveux
parfaitement bosse très bien merci
madame merci messieurs d'avoir participé
à cette émission
merci de votre attention et puis bien
sûr on suivra très attentivement
l'actualité concernant general electric
à belfort et toute l'actualité
économique industrielle en bourgogne
franche comté
merci encore bon dimanche après midi à
tous au revoir
[Musique]